قناه الخارجيه الروسيه الى الهجوم الذي
وقع امس في منطقه داخل الاراضي الروسيه تم
باسلحه النيتو وتوعدت بانه لن يمر دون
عقاب هذا وجددت اوكرانيا نفيها للاتهامات
لها بالضلوع في الهجوم للمزيد حول الموضوع
معنى من مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي
ومنكياف مراسل الجزيره حسن الشوبكي ونبدا
مع رانيا وكيف تتعامل روسيا مع مرحله ما
بعد هذا الهجوم الذي تقول اوكرانيا انها
لا علاقه لها به وانه صراع داخلي روسي
بدايه وسيله لابد من الاشاره الى ان الملف
ما حدث امس في برانسك لا يزال مغلقا يعني
نحن نعلم انه قبل قليل الرئيس الروسي قد
باشر في اجتماع مغلق مع اعضاء مجلس الامن
الروسي اجتماعه هذا الاجتماع مكرز بدرجه
الاولى لمكافحه الارهاب وحمايه المنشات
الحيويه الروسيه من الخطر الارهابي واود
الاشاره الى ان ما حدث امس في القرى
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا توضعته روسيا في
خانه الاعمال الارهابيه حتى هذه اللحظه
هاتين القريتين لا تزال لا تزالان مطوقتان
لا يسمح لاحد بالدخول الى الداخل ومواقع
الامر وسيله يعني المعطيات شحيحه وضوابيه
حول ما يجري حاليا في هذه المنطقه التي لا
يسمح لاحد الدخول اليها كل ما هو معروف
حتى هذه اللحظه وهو انه القوات المسلحه
الروسيه دفعت بمن
قام بالتسرع من الق او بجماعات التقريبيه
بحسب وصف الجانب الروسي بالدخول تم دفعها
نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه ومن ثم تم قصفها
ولكن لا معطيات ما ان كان الحديث يدور عن
بقايا من هذه القوات المسلحه التي تسللت
الى الداخل حتى هذه اللحظه لا تزال اعمال
التنشيط قائمه هناك العديد من المتفجرات
والالغام التي تعمل القوات المسلحه
الروسيه على ازالتها وعليه فان الاوضاع
حتى هذه اللحظه يمكن القول انها غير
محسومه في هذه المنطقه من جهه اخرى بالفعل
هناك كانت الاتهامات مباشره لحلف شمال
الاطلس بالتواطئ مع الجانب الاوكراني كون
الاسلحه بحسب الجانب الروسيه التي تم
استخدامها لتنفيذ الهجوم على هاتين
القريتين واستهداف المدنيين فيها هي اسلحه
حصلت عليها اوكرانيا من حلف شمال الاطلسي
بشكل عام وذلك وفقا لتصريحات الكرملين
هذه هذا العمل لن يبقى دون رد دون معاقبه
المسؤولين عنه ولكن هنا ايضا لا بد من
الاشاره لان تحقيقات قائمه لاسيما فيما
يتعلق بالاوضاع في هاتين المنطقتين
والكرم نتعهد في وقت سابق بانه سيتم اتخاذ
كل الاجراءات الضروريه للحيلوله دون تكرار
مثل هذا الحادث وهنا ود الاشاره الى ان
الحدود الحدود بين روسيا واوكرانيا هي
حدود تمتد لي مئات الكيلومترات وهي عباره
عن غابات شاسعه وفي واقع الامر يصعب
السيطره عليها او مراقبتها بشكل كامل
وعليه فانه بعد هذا الحادث على ما يبدو
وهذا ما يركز عليه اليوم في اجتماعها
الرئيس الروسيركز على هذه الجزئيه على وجه
التحديد حول مساله مكافحه الارهاب الحيلون
دون تكرار هادئ هذا الحدث والحمايه
المنشات الحيويه على طول المناطق الحدوديه
ابقي معنا رانيا حسن شوبكي في كييف
اوكرانيا سارعت الى نفي علاقتها بهذا
الهجوم لكن روسيا توجه اتهام صريح بان هذا
السلاح هو يتبع للناتو من الاسلحه التي
قدمت لاوكرانيا هل صدر جديد بخصوص هذه
الاتهامات
نعم وسيله النفي لاوكراني يتكرر لليوم
الثاني على التوالي وان اوكرانيا تقول ان
ليس لها علاقه بالصراعات الداخليه الروسيه
اخر ما حرر في هذا الامر ما كتبه وعلق على
الاحداث عبر صفحته في تويتر ميخائيل
بودلياك المستشار في مكتب الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه قال بالحرف ان هنالك منشات يتم
ضربها وان هنالك طائرات بدون طيار مجهوله
الهويه وان هنالك اشتباكات لعصابات تضرب
مناطق ماهوله بالسكان في الداخل الروسي
قال ان كل هذا يؤشر على حاله عدم
الاستقرار التي وصل اليها الاتحاد الروسي
بسبب حربه وبسبب الاوضاع الداخليه الروسيه
وقال ايضا اكرر انه لا علاقه لاوكرانيا
بالصراعات الداخليه الروسيه وكان قد اكد
في اكثر من موقف حول هذه العمليه تحديدا
ان منطقه
هذه المنطقه لها اهميه استراتيجيه بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا وان اوكرانيا تدافع عن حدودها
وان هنالك جبهات مشتعله كثيره وهذه
المنطقه لا اهميه لها ايضا على ذات المعنى
وبذات الصعيد وسيله قالت الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه المتحدث باسم الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه
قال بان المساله التي تمت تشير الى ان
هنالك استيقاظ من
الداخل الروسي ومن الشعب الروسي ضد ما
سماها ديكتاتوريه بوتين بمعنى ان هنالك
هذه الحرب جرت
الاثار السلبيه والفلتان في كل مكان وان
الحرب التي مست كل منزل اوكراني هي بالفعل
ايضا مس كل منزل روسي هذا ما تعتبره
الاستخبارات الروسيه في العموم وسيله يمكن
القول ان مثل هذه الامور تناقش هنا في
كييف باعتبار ان روسيا تهرب الى
التبرير للداخل لداخل داخل المجتمع الروسي
بان المساله حتى تبرر حربها على اوكرانيا
هكذا يقول الكثير من المسؤولين هنا
ويقولون ايضا انها ربما تكرر مكانه تفعله
في الحرب الشيشانيه بانها كانت تفعل مثل
هذه الافعال شكرا جزيلا لك حسن الشوبكي من
رانيا دريدي من بريان